[Music]
this is every damn day today we're
talking about Logan Paul he's a
controversial YouTube star and he's
announced he's making a documentary
about his quote-unquote difficult year
guys does Logan Paul need the daily vlog
I don't know what this guy does just a
lot of stuff I can say about him I don't
know why I don't like him I just can't
watch the video he he just looks like
the type of guy who bones a girl come
sit bones ask her how she's getting home
as he wipes to because you don't even
know if we can use that but it's true I
totally agree she's like a terrible like
in a spider web of awful it's so bad the
Japanese forest thing he tased a rat so
let's so the Japanese forest thing is so
there is a suicide force in Japan he
went there and filmed actual people who
had died committed suicide in that
forest which is toe gross just so unlike
so many levels because it's like what
did you expect to find there at this
place that is like you know we should go
do
use an Auslan question I feel like I
don't have any no I mean I get he's bad
right he's bad I know I know when
watching it it's bad to watch but it's
entertaining and that's why it has so
many of you what you do you disagree
that's why it has so many views it's
entered company I don't know I don't
know he's so big he's bad he's bad he to
me is like the evil version of like
America's Funniest Home Videos yeah I
mean it's like we watched like people
fall down on those things but it's like
it's a family harming everyone else
self harm it's like let's hit everyone
else with nuts and animals there's a
video and this is not entertaining
there's a video where he hands people
who don't have money back of money and
they go wow this is so nice because
there's lots of shows where they give
you money and it's nice and then he rips
it out of their hand so bad do that
that's the meanest it's so it's so you
know we say bones but I am like that
would be that would be crazy to watch
that's what happens you get so riled up
and angry that you anger watch them yeah
I think a lot of anger watching I've
just never I don't succumb to the anger
watching pressure to this afternoon when
I watch their video live in Scrooge
McDuck 2040 are you guys gonna vote for
them
there you have it Logan Paul he's
running for president and we're on board
[Laughter]
I'm Chris Kyle I'm gonna act on some
hypothetical questions you're gonna tell
you what you would've did I'm gonna tell
you what I would've did this is what I
would do all right what would you do if
someone poops in the kiddie pool well
first of all I don't use the pool so it
wouldn't really be an issue and I don't
belong to a pool and it's truly a
non-issue what oh I do wonderful okay I
guess I would call someone to pick it up
I wouldn't pick it up myself I'm sorry
I'm not a good citizen I don't know okay
what I would do is probably ban all the
kids from the kiddie pool but I will
keep it in there so you can see this is
what y'all did somebody did this and
y'all need to learn responsibility
somebody no I wouldn't let him swim in
it anymore but I'll make him look at it
you know me almost like it look what you
did kids but then it wouldn't just
disintegrate from on the clown order but
they need to know it turns into brown
water I don't think that's all I mean I
figured it'd come like tea it's like tea
like poop tea
all right question goes to which he goes
to Ryan no Ryan what would you do if you
walk through a swarm of fruit flies or
nets or something like the color
yeah what would I do would you do I
would I'd go like that I go I got I go
like this and then I would move out of
the way because they're they're annoying
generally I don't agree with you Ryan
but I'm gonna have to agree with you yes
you can't do those max everywhere man I
wish we could do something bout than
that interesting it was just a you know
what I'm talking about that's not what
you do an ice cream broke the ice cream
cone is melon fast dude you wanna take
it easy get a bowl of some let it drip
into the boat and drink it like like
soup okay what would you do if your air
conditioner sort of blown out actual ice
chips if it started blowing at actual
ice chips ice chips coming that's a bad
thing necessarily
you know what I would do I would grab my
ice cream bowl okay and I would collect
the chips mm-hmm and then I have some
extra ice cream water spectacular answer
other than thing I always become like a
hero like I would keep it plugged in and
I'll be like like you don't like mr.
freeze but I'd be a positive person in
the community and I will use all my
frosty air conditioner powers for
positive but we're like an air
conditioner both ice chips
you would shoot ice chips
doors not kids that's Frozone from
incredible exactly I'd be like so you
would keep in the pool but you
would be learn but that okay what size
chips I would be a superhero I'm very
excited to see if you have kids what
they turn out everybody's the rapid-fire
round
I'm not giving the answer what would you
do if there was a heat wave now now
there is a heat wave guys ice packs on
my body
boom continue living the way I do now he
go hit a banana sleeping naked on the
couch until my roommate asked me to stop
last week talking about baby that was
just me rail and I'm doing the same
thing had to do it not in her house
could that be weird we work together
hello
I'm Jordan and once a week I take a
little more psychedelics than usual and
write in my journal these are my
thoughts how do you make friends asking
for a friend
this has been I feel like every Logan
Paul video is a setup for one of Chris's
questions you just tased the rap what
would you do people like them maybe oh
you know problems like help girls get
away with being funny you know they're
like hot girls can say like hot guy yeah
I mean I don't find him attractive but I
think the general population find so
much other I'm just saying aesthetically
he's like not bad-looking yeah have you
spin little mustache that he sometimes
has that is like that's how much does
she do Jordan has Jordan
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
well this has been every damn day see
you next week
[Music]
you